We are going to start with the most difficult thing in the entire semester.
It's about how to pronounce my name.
Okay.
All right.
Uh,
so,
uh,
I am from Hungary and this is pronounced as Károly Zsolnai. Károly is essentially the
equivalent of Karl in,
in Deutsche or Charles in English and Zsolnai [inaudible].
There's low to for that spoke,
so I'm sorry.
So it is pronounced as coward.
If you imagined this as like an English word that in,
forget the l and you just pronounce it like that.
So it's Katori.
Okay.
So,
uh,
I'd like to hear some examples.
So Calorie.
Okay.
Yes,
yes.
Excellent.
That'd be louder.
[inaudible]
so he's kind of way,
so it's,
it's all,
it's like a y style.
One more time.
Louder.
Yes.
Excellent.
Okay.
Wow.
It's amazing.
Okay.
Now comes the hard parts.
So this is pronounced as Joel night.
Okay.
So all it's Hungarian is a weird language whereZ and s is actually one letter.
So if you take a look at the Hungarian alphabet,
there's a letter that is z.
There's a letter that is s and there's a third letter that is zen as together.
So [inaudible] so this is pronounced as you show them.
So the h is the difficult part.
Okay.
There's all night.
Wow.
Yes
I can.
Can you pronounce it
immediately?
Nailing.
Okay.
Yes.
It showed val,
it was are,
are you,
are you Hungarian
as parents?
Maybe.
Secretly.
Wow.
That's great.
Sure.
It's not sure.
Jordan.
Jordan is June.
Okay.
Is there someone who I have forgotten or everyone,
everyone knows what's up.
Okay,
so this is what we're going to be doing.
So the amazing thing is that when you see images on the internet like that,
sometimes it's difficult to find out if this is,
if it is computer graphics or is it a real photograph.
And this is one of these examples.
This is an an uh,
an example.
Uh,
and this is the work of amazing engineers and amazing artists.
And we are going to be talking about how to compute images like that.
And if you look at this,
well when you download the slides at home,
you will see that on the lens,
the dust is modeled here.
You can see just some small splotches,
but you can actually see pieces of dust on the lens of the camera.
And this is computed with the computer program and by the end of the semester
you are going to know everything about this.
How is this exactly computed?
Every single pixel,
uh,
just a few,
thanks of all the organization,
there's gonna be assignments,
they take up 40% of your grade and these assignments we'll have,
uh,
most of them will have the theoretical parts and on paper I'll do under how to
understand what's going on,
uh,
in nature.
And there will be,
there will be also programming exercises,
but they are not really that programming exercises.
It's,
it's mostly using programs,
understanding what they are doing and maybe modifying them here and there.
But you are not going to write my huge rendering engines and things like that.
So,
uh,
don't worry about this.
Uh,
does 60% part is uh,
an oral exam and this is going to take place after the semester,
uh,
with me.
So this is,
uh,
some friendly discussion about what you have learned or a not so friendly
discussion if you haven't learned anything,
that's never been the case.
So I'm just getting a,
and this is going to take place within,
but you can choose.
So
if you would like to have the exam with Thomas,
that's also fine.
But I would like to note that I am an engineer and he's a brilliant physicist.
So if you choose,
you know who to,
who to try to deal with.
I choose the engineer.
I don't know about you,
but
it's just,
just a suggestion and there can be some kind of individual contribution.
So if you find some errors on the slides,
if you add some figures that hey,
I don't like this figure,
I've drawn something better than that.
There's going to be programs that we work with.
If you find some parts in there or if you can extend it in any way,
you can get plus points.
And this applies to basically any kind of contribution that you have.
A,
this is the book that we're gonna learn from.
So there is a,
I'm trying to cover everything and at some point I will say that,
yeah,
please open the book if you would like to know more about this.
But,
uh,
whatever I tell you here is going to be enough for a exam.
So it's not going to happen as,
hey,
why haven't you read,
I don't know,
a patient,
he kind of a 59,
don't you remember that?
This is not going to happen.
So this is to augment your knowledge.
If you would like to move more and this is a great place to do and this has a
website,
this can be bought at different places.
There is some sample chapters and
uh,
before buying you can take a look whether you like it enough or not.
So it's pretty cool that it has sample chapters.
Uh,
let's start with what you shouldn't expect from this course.
I'll just run through it and there's not going to be rigorous derivations of
every imaginable equation that you have.
So there are courses where there is this neverending infinite loop like in
programming in an infinite loop off definition,
CRM corrolary definition,
theory and theory.
M lemme uh,
raise your hand if yes,
she was being taught a course like that.
I'm not gonna tell anyone.
Okay,
so I'm not going to,
so I've had a lot of these courses and I've,
I've had enough so,
so I'm,
I'm trying to do it differently.
There's not going to be,
unless,
uh,
derivations,
there's not going to be an under stream of formula as well without explanation.
There's going to be formulaic,
but with explanations we are going to play with all of them and you are going to
understand that the core meaning right,
these things.
And uh,
at the same time,
please don't expect to understand everything.
If you open,
for instance,
the Lux render,
a source called,
this is like a half a million line of code,
a project,
one of the best vendors out there.
But there's many,
many really good renders.
You will not understand every single thing that is there.
But you will understand how the light transport part works as early as possible.
And the most important thing I've,
I've put it there with bolts because this is what students love.
You don't have to memorize any of the formula.
Okay?
So I will never tell you that.
Okay,
give me this formula and he will have to remember it off the top of your head.
I don't care.
I mean if you're an engineer at a company,
you sit down,
you need to solve a problem.
If you don't remember something,
what do you do?
Google and Youtube for it.
This is,
it's not important to remember things.
It's important to understand this.
So if you look at the formula,
you will have to understand what is going on.
Uh,
and that's intuition.
This is what I would like you to have as much as possible,
but you don't need to memorize any of these.
Now what you should expect from this course is how to simulate light in a simple
and elegant way.
This is going to be a surprise at first because things are going to look
complicated and by the end we are going to derive,
do really simple solutions for that that can be implemented in 200 lines of c
plus plus.
So this 200 lance can compute something that's almost beautiful as what you have
seen here.
And I have written this piece of code and every theory that we uh,
learn about you are going to see them in code in in fact there's going to be an
entire lecture on a code review.
Like let's go through this render and see there is slicks approximation,
there is not as low dose,
this and that and every single thing that you'll learn here you are going to see
unicode.
It's,
it's not just a flying out the window enough.
You will know why nature looks like as it does in real life.
And you won't be wondering that there's the so many beautiful things and why
have a pi seeing them the way they are.
Why are they looking at the way they are?
And you will know about also most of the state of the art in global
illumination.
This means that yes,
we will start with algorithms from 1968
and we will end with algorithms from uh,
this year right from two weeks ago or in the next few weeks because the siggraph
is coming like the cigarette papers,
the biggest conference with them,
that stuff.
The bunch is coming in the next few weeks and I'm going to read through it and
the materials will be updated to the very latest works.
And another thing is that a really important,
uh,
is that you will be able to visualize and understand complicated formula in a
really intuitive way.
So I would like you to learn something that's not only light transport specific,
but you will be able to use this knowledge wherever you go,
whatever kind of a mathematical problems you have.
This knowledge will be useful and we will see from the very first lecture and
the most important thing is that you will see the world differently.
There is,
there is lots of beautiful things in nature and you won't be able to stop
looking at it.
So you will,
you will perhaps like,
uh,
taking the train or public transport the big more than before because there's,
there's so many intricate,
delicate things to see,
uh,
that you haven't seen before.
You have looked,
but you haven't seen them before.